everybody how's everybody doing today
that's me that's the stock all right so
I'm gonna talk about the future but
first we're gonna talk about the 90s
bait-and-switch I actually used to live
up here in the 90s I grew up up here and
the fashion just hasn't changed at all
it was it's just sweat shirts and fleece
from REI back in the 90s there'd be like
some neon windbreakers but it's
basically the same so back in the 90s
there was actually like this real fight
like kind of a war over what the future
of the internet would look like there
wasn't really an established application
platform
it was globally accessible and the view
of a lot of people including like vast
majority of the tech industry actually
and Bill Gates was that you would have
this thing that bill liked to call the
information superhighway which was like
you would just connect to companies
products and they would all be like
unique and then you would download their
software and then connect to like their
backends and stuff to think about it now
it sounds relatively dystopic like you
had just connected these corporate sites
and get their content but like AOL was
like the most successful version of this
right which was it was a content portal
and rather than using the web you would
use this content portal and everybody
thought that this was gonna win not a
lot of people thought in the web was
gonna win and if you're looking at them
like yeah you can kind of see why like
this is a little more useable like
there's a taxonomy I can click on things
that I can do and like what is over here
and they had this amazing thing called
like keywords so like if I was like hey
I have this awesome website so you type
like HTTP colon slash slash and like the
browser's were dumb they would not fill
this in for you and and then uh Oprah
like every day on her show would get up
there and Oprah would be like yes
keyword Oprah look it up on AOL and then
you get all this content from Oprah on
AOL like of course this is gonna win
Oprah is gonna win we're not gonna win
and just like I'm generally better
experience but the thing that ended up
happening is that the web had this thing
called URLs and then people who publish
them
would link to other people's URLs and
that seems like a really simple thing
and it's like this primitive that we
really take for granted but like the if
you wanted to publish something on AOL
your first step was like be Oprah and
then step two was like pay people to put
up content on the web like anybody can
get an earl and you can put up stuff and
then you can link to other people's
stuff and even though worlds were much
worse to stay than keywords they allow
these kinds of network effects to happen
because you can link to other people's
stuff so like I make my Oprah blog we
didn't have blogs in the 90s but you get
my point
and then like somebody like publishes
their list of favorite Oprah sites and
somebody makes an Oprah web ring and
this all kind of piles on together and
eventually what you end up with is this
big network graph of different people
providing different content and so Oprah
is content on a o L was a lot better
than like any one person's favorite
blogs or anything like that but when you
take the entire value of this big
network and all this activity that's
happening and all this exponential
growth of this network around all that
content it just doesn't even compare
anymore to the content that you had
inside of these portals and so these
network effects are effectively why the
web one and when we when we go to
compare the value of AOL and all just
like really high end well published
content we're comparing it to this the
value of the web which is like this huge
exponentially growing graph of data and
value that's why the web one and I think
that is really easy today to forget
about these primitives and why they were
so important we really need to unwind
our view of the web today when we think
about the web we think about standards
and browsers and web frameworks and
JavaScript and like that is all very
important and like I you know I did no
js' stuff for nine years I think that
like javascript is very important I
serve on the node foundation it is a
very important thing but if we're
thinking about what are the current
limitations of the web and what are the
primitives that we need in order to move
forward we really need to come back to
the basics and unwind and think about
URLs and links so this is an earl and
there's basically three distinct parts
there's a transport
and authority and then a reference to
the content they're getting and you can
sort of think about this backwards right
first you name content that you're going
to publish so you create some kind of
name for it or like an index then
there's the who who do I ask for on the
internet for this content right and then
the transport says like how I ask this
person for that content and so when I
link to somebody else's site I'm
actually giving them a central location
to go and look this up I'm saying go to
this authority and ask somebody for this
content right and that's that's the base
primitive that we built everything for
the last 20 years on centralization is
baked into that primitive right
it's federated in in a general sense but
like the whole web is federated but
every individual actor is actually
centralized so web locations are more
than just static assets in the browser
right static assets in the browser I can
manipulate they're part of the open web
like I can and do change like everything
in facebook
sorry I don't really go to Facebook but
Twitter like I remove all the ads I
change words that make me stressed out
like Trump to things that don't stress
me out like daisies like it's just you
know I have like a series of dumb
extensions to just change everything
about that experience the problem though
is that like Twitter and and modern web
applications in general aren't just
these static assets they pull
information out of AP eyes and those AP
eyes are addressed by those URLs they're
like in these central locations I can't
just replace it the way that I can
replace stuff that's in my browser and
so this means that data centralization
is baked in to multi-user applications
on the web today there just isn't a good
way for me to go and build an
application that multiple users interact
with and have relationships between
those peoples data without just
centralizing in an entire content silo
and putting an API in front of it so
this is one of the largest cost drivers
of modern applications it makes them
expensive like Brian's talking at the
beginning of the day was brilliant
because you know it really is pennies
now to just run thousands of function
executions in the cloud but if you log
like a little bit of data from all of
those calls the storage cost of the
is more expensive than the processing of
the actual cloud functions storage
actually still does cost money and
unlike lot functions that like Evan flow
with like how active your website is
storage only really increases over time
it's why it's such a good business to be
in like we're here so but the the
biggest problem that we really have with
with these data silos isn't just it like
we can't get our data out of them or
that they're opaque which they are it's
that they you have to basically build an
ad model to support most large websites
and that again comes back to URLs and
links if I want to benefit from the
network effects of the web I have to be
a link you to my content which means
that my content has to be publicly
accessible it can't be behind a paywall
so like any application that gets
popular enough through these network
effects is gonna have to be ad supported
in order to fund all these costs
eventually these a driven businesses
started to get smarter and smarter they
started to adopt a lot of really good
machine learning and new algorithms and
eventually what they figured out is that
the best way to capture your attention
for the longest amount of time is to
keep moving you towards more and more
extreme content and so you're
effectively radicalizing people like on
purpose because it's a very good way to
keep you watching YouTube like forever
and our current like we don't we just
have no recourse right like the people
in this room are developers like me
we're going to build the next version of
one of these applications and we have no
other tool than to build it the same way
that we've always built it and end up
with all the exact same problems again
our only other resources literally to
yell at billionaires and try to ask them
to change their algorithms to make less
money like they didn't become
billionaires by making less money off of
these algorithms is just not gonna
happen so anyway let's like so like how
do we even start to address this problem
it seems like very very like huge and it
is I've spent like 10 years trying to
think about it and here's the real issue
right so we have a web application it
talks to like multiple api's those api
is end up talking to databases and other
storage solutions and like I've written
databases like a bunch of them from
quite a while now and what a database
does really is that it take
the serialization of like your data
structure and then it stores it on disk
and it stores it on disk with a bunch of
other computers usually in a network and
it makes guarantees about the state of
that data the thing that you you
probably don't even realize as a
developer because you kind of take it
for granted is that there are state
guarantees and consistency guarantees in
that serialization to disk that bubble
all the way up to the API and the state
that comes out then and then all the
caching layers that we build on those
api is to make them fast and so if we
want to like remove this API layer that
is so problematic and figure out how to
distribute it and decentralize that and
make it part of the open web we actually
have to go and dig all the way into
where that data gets serialized and
bring that into like into the browser
into the open web into a space that we
can actually work with so this will
become a little bit clearer as as I as I
move along but that's why we have to dig
so deep into this problem is because you
all of these layers in between have
consistency guarantees that bubble level
all the way from how you store data we
have to literally start to rethink what
happened when we have a data structure
in memory and we need to share it or to
serialize it long term like what happens
when it leaves the space of the memory
of our programs that's the problem we
need to solve so we come back to the
Earle like we did the Earle has a
central authority in it we're gonna have
all the same problems so like to get rid
of the transport and the authority also
because we don't have an authority we
don't have like like the authority also
provides a namespace so we can't have
like these human names we go and create
the things we can do so eventually
people figure it out that you can do
this thing where you hash the content
and people have been using hashes for
very long time but every five years or
so we look at hashing and we realized
that there's like another problem that
we can solve with this and another whole
scope of issues that we can solve with
it and so our view of what we can do
with Cooper graphic hashing keeps
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
right and promise I'm not going to talk
about block chains so we we have so what
we have this primitive now called
content address ability or content
dressing right and the interesting thing
about content addressability is that we
get a way to address data without an
authority without a location without a
transport we can get the data from
anywhere from anybody and we have a
cryptographic guarantee that like you
told me about this hash and I got it
from like some Rando and I looked at the
data and said Oh ad does match this hash
it's kind of brilliant and then if that
data has inside of it
other hashes then changing any of those
links inside of that data changes the
hash and so we have another
cryptographic guarantee if the day ever
changes I'm just gonna move along and
start to show some of this in practice
at this point because either you're
following along or you're not and you're
not gonna get it if I keep just talking
okay so a protocol out we created this
thing called a CID or content identifier
so CID is just a very very flexible way
to say okay we have we have a hash and
then we need to know how to interpret
that hash to get links out of it because
we're not all going to use the exact
same data format so that's all it is so
you can think of it as like sort of like
a replacement for the earldom to graphic
hashing okay so if I want to like you
know publish my blog data and you want
to go read it you would say oh go get
this this content hash and then you
would get back this object it has my
posts in it okay and here's here's the
fun thing it just doesn't matter how you
get this hash right like I'm not gonna
talk about a bunch of peer-to-peer
technologies and dhts and ways to get it
data because it literally doesn't matter
you could pull it out of a centralized
store you could pull it out of a local
storage cache like anyway the nobody
cares like it's all you know the same
for together guarantees so this is how
we can create truly decentralized data
structures without worrying about like
oh well did I authenticate with the
right peer-to-peer network and things
like that anyway inside of this data
structure I have a list of posts and
then one of those posts just points to
another cid it's just a link right we're
just creating new link data just like we
did in the internet and then when I go
and get that C ID from wherever again
I will then get the text for that post
fairly simple okay
but now Sally like has a list of her
favorite blogs and she's like oh yeah
well Michels blog is this hash so boom
that's in my list I'm not publishing
that data and Heather creates an
aggregator and she's like oh cool
there's this new link now and now we're
starting to build some of the same
network effects that we had in the early
web with links for data so all of my
data that I publish all my tweets
they're not just like locked up in
Twitter or locked up in Facebook or
wherever they're actually part of like a
completely decentralized system that
spans the internet where anybody can
link to anybody's data so the really
cool thing here is like different people
can be hosting this data right it
doesn't have to live in the same place
if I'm only looking at Heather's
aggregator and I don't really want to go
look at my blog I don't even have to
resolve that link or all of this could
be on my computer because I pulled it
all down to read all of this data
offline nothing changes in the data
structures it's all just content
addressed okay so let's look at like a
more kind of real-world use case so
different universities published in
omics data different scientific data and
then people run regression analysis over
that data the way this looks today is
that they publish it in like just random
different FTP sites and tarballs and
stuff and then everybody goes and
downloads that and like different
universities try to mirror each other's
data but they all use different
protocols and it's like really really
messy so if we if we imagine this world
where we have content address data and
that you actually put all of that
genomics data into content dress that I
can create a regression data set that is
also a hash they just point to all the
hashes that I'm going to run against
right at all of these different places
and I can pull all of that data down in
real time from all of these universities
or mirrors of those universities or
local caches again all of the sort of
deliverability semantics are then
removed from the data structures so we
get a lot more reliability we get a lot
more permanence and like archive ability
which is really important and then the
really cool thing is that when I get
that result that regression result that
ran across that entire data set I can
point down at individual parts of the
data right like the same way that you
would put
like look down and look at individual
posts I can look at you know this is
just a part of the genomics data that
match some query that I had and again I
can pull down all that data and riho
stit and republish it but actually my
data structure is the only thing that I
worry about need to worry about being
published and staying alive all of these
links they go off to other places those
are in the network those exist I don't
have to Rijo s-- them I'm just adding
new value to or and also deriving value
from the data that's in the network
similarly like let's imagine like a
Twitter that's built on you centralized
data structures so Bob Alice and Sally
and Heather are all publishing their
feeds somewhere and my feed is just a
pointer to all of their feeds that's
what I'm looking at right and my
favorites is just pointing to all the
individual treats inside of their data
structures and now they're hosting them
or I'm hosting them or it doesn't matter
right that's kind of the point and of
course this data structure is the exact
this looks exactly like a slide from a
little bit ago even though these data
structures are completely different like
the way that we would want to do you
know genomics data and the way that we
would do tweets looks very different
from like you know the actual data
structures point of view but I'm able to
display it in the same way here because
it's all built on this same really
really tiny primitive this continent in
the fire so CID is a pointer that spans
the internet essentially you can think
about it like when you're building data
structures and you're building B trees
like if you've you know had a Google
interview and then never done that again
you you have pointers to data it's like
a very simple programming concept but if
you think about a pointer that can span
the internet then now you can imagine
building out data structures like B
trees that span more than just you know
the memory space inside of my hard drive
and also don't just span you know a
particular data silo for a particular
website as quote as me I said done smart
so so but at the end of the day what we
end up with is a network of data this
hugely giant valuable network of data
write effectively like an Internet of
data just built on this simple primitive
right
now if you start to imagine all this
data out there existing all these people
building value on top of it you stop
trying to compare this to a particular
Amazon offering or this to Facebook or
this to Twitter right
those are huge applications it's hard to
imagine anybody ever competing with them
but just like my a hotel blog was not
competing or sorry my Oprah blog was not
competing with Oprah's content the whole
network was competing with that content
in the same way if we're creating this
internet a data and deriving all of this
value those old applications that are
locked up in data silos are actually
competing with the entire value of the
network that means that we can actually
win we can actually like move all of
this data and start moving our next
application basis all into this new
model where we're not locked up in all
these companies and all these data silos
anymore so that's the vision that we
have that we're trying to build I'm
working on that a protocol labs a lot of
people are working on this a lot of
people are working looking at content or
disability where it's like the earliest
days ever like we are still implementing
fundamental data structures we're doing
a lot of new research and new work if
you're really interested in this I would
like really encourage you to go check
out this spec repository this is
probably like the best list of grammar
and current work that we have like in
like a more human readable format and
we're of course working in like a lot of
new content and then on top of these
data structures we built things like IP
FS the interplanetary file system which
can move your files around and all of
that I peeled d stands for
interplanetary linked data yeah because
we we love acronyms that immediately
make the intergalactic sonbai Beastie
Boys playing my head so but anyway that
that is my talk I finished up a little
bit early very nice I always talked
faster than I wanted to so thank you so
much and please join us on making the
next version of the web
[Applause]